Okay Otto
Time for a game of table tennis H.O.R.S.E.
Let's do it
Let's start off with an easy one
Forehand around the net
Your go!
Not that hard!
Fairly easy
Okay, ghost serve into the cup
There we go!
Hit the cups?
Go ahead
That was a bit too easy
Yeah
Let's step it up to 5 cups in a row
Okay
Okay, serve around the Pongfinity net post
[You can buy the net from pongfinity.store]
Was it?
I will set the score for Miikka to try to beat
Ok so 56 is the score to beat
How many did I get?
Otto won that one
Easy
Let's see if Miikka can do this
That wasn't even close!
Close but not enough
The one who drops the egg first looses
It's starting to break more and more
I don't want it anymore!
That was like a game of hot potato!
Yea, I don't want it! Take it!
Ok so you have to get the ball to roll on the table
Okay
Like that
Not bad
I think yours was a bit better
1 point match of mini pong
Miikka is going to throw this
And I'm going to hit in the air
Nice shot!
That's how you do it
Close
Otto, I think you are going to like this one!
I can also play that game
Ok Miikka, your turn!
Yeah... I think we are just going to call it a draw
And guys if you want to get yourself one of these cool table tennis nets
Go hit the link in the description
You can buy them from our web store
Ready for this?